on peut pas conclure à l'inaction de la
justice ni à son impunité les chiffres
en sont me semble-t-il les
pousstoufflantes démonstration et je
veux mettre en garde tous ceux qui
publiquement tiennent ce
discours mais au-delà de la critique on
est habitué à être critiqué mais ce qui
me chagrine le plus c'est que c'est
susceptible de décourager bon nombre de
victimes qui se finalement qu'on laisse
dans une espèce d'aquabonisme ah ben ça
sert à rien parce que la justice ne
condamne pas parce que la justice
n'enquête pas parce que la justice et
cetera je vous ai donné un certain
nombre de chiffres je souhaite vraiment
mettre un terme à à à à à ces choses qui
sont dites et qui ont surtout comme
effet délétaire et dévastateur le fait
de
démobiliser des victimes qui souhaiterit
déposer plainte et qui se disent à quoi
bon ce discours est un discours
absolument
contreproductif entendre à longueur de
plateau de télé porter plainte ça sert à
rien que la justice fait
rien quel est l'xiste voilà c'est
absolument insupportable ce n'est pas
conforme à la réalité et moi je veux
dire au victimes portez plainte et
saisissez la justice évidemment tout
n'est pas
parfait mais nous faisons tout et
j'allais dire tous ensemble pour que les
choses bougent et qu'elles aillent dans
le bon sens on doit poursuivre les
efforts pour accueillir la parole des
victimes pour la respecter l'accueillir
et la respecter et pour moi les choses
vont évidemment de de paire du dépôt de
la plainte à l'issue de la procédure
pénale et il faut évidemment redonner
aux victimes confiance dans
l'institution judiciaire